just a light pitter patter to start us
off yeah a little ASMR
how are you good how are you good
um
I got a song I want to play yeah
I don't really know how I would start
this song I'll call this song
hey didn't you hear Cody's doing a
charity where he runs
was it
a mile per thousand mile per thousand
yeah
um This song is called
we're donating five thousand dollars
so you run a five extra five miles wait
actually yes who is we are are you
serious right now yeah right now yeah
wait what is this real or is it yeah
actually and everybody go run it up so
Cody has to run no Jillian miles go to
Cody trains
uh YouTube channel where uh Luke can you
pull it up and we'll just I'm like gonna
cry this is [__] awesome why are you
gonna cry well because like we're not
like we have two weeks left I really
thought that we'd get to 50K pretty
easily oh and I'm having a hard time
like getting like you know oh no Finish
Line here come on now so 5K brings me to
40 miles 40K that's 40 miles let's get
Cody to uh can we get a angel investor
donor please to donate a hundred million
dollars please no don't yeah well I'm
yeah that's
I'm kind of torn on that yeah because
all right so you're at 35
971 now so let's go ahead and throw a
Fiverr in there we just put 5 000 more
on there
this is sick because by donating through
TMG I guess it's also me donating yeah
you ever wanted to
you ever wanted to donate to yourself
but hey half of it's me yeah that's true
a two and a half miles is it that yeah I
appreciate that I'm gonna think about
you during those two and a half miles
just for those two and a half just for
and then um yeah as soon as you get to
2.5
001 yeah you better switch it over dude
yeah I'm gonna think about me yeah yeah
it goes
oh
let's go and to be clear if you're
really happy about this like you get
over 50 000 you have to run more miles
than that right yeah
so people should donate what man I wish
we had someone come in here and walk in
with just a [__] hundred thousand
dollar check and you're like okay let's
calm down and then we get like another
dude in here with a hundred thousand
dollar check
and it just starts should we call Mr
Beast Mr Beast oh this would be a great
time yo send this to Mr Beast it's a
great time out there do not send this to
Mr Pizza that's not funny it's not funny
wait wait no no
okay again I'm torn because I I do want
to raise
the most amount of money possible yeah
yeah yeah so do send it to Mr B's
but you know listen there's a cap on the
miles that I'm gonna run you said there
was no cap on them when did I say did I
say no I asked you on insanely chill I
was capping
there's no cap dude we're gonna make him
run 500 000 yeah you're never you're not
gonna get the podcast for a full year
because you're just gonna be on Forest
Gump mode
you're getting the run back we'll see
you in a year dude you have to run so
much yeah just doing shitty Zoom
episodes or I'm out of breath the entire
time
where are you at [__] you I still
haven't forgiven you
thank you guys yeah for sure amazing so
now we're at forty one thousand dollars
for after school All-Stars that's
amazing I really appreciate that
thank you guys
what other sports are we betting on
b-ball um I've been doing you're doing
this all legally NBA and the fights and
um I've been hockey I've been in
Lacrosse
uh
I'm like lacrosse bro I had a bajillion
dollar idea what we we collab with steak
okay
and we build a replica of the horse
racing machine
but it's NASCAR
oh my God we put that [__] together
really good idea you put that [__] in
Kansas City or Vegas Vegas too but I
mean just Kansas City Tennessee wherever
we will ether Middle America's bank
that's a really good idea we will take
all their money yeah
that's a great idea just brandishable
start a casino yeah should we
sure let's just start one I love it we
donated a charity at the beginning of
this and we're like actually let's take
money back from people yeah you could
take that concept of things racing and
just you know apply it to anything dude
you could oh man racist yeah yeah yeah
racist machines yeah
the most racist machines in all of
America Formula One the NASCAR
uh you know formula of race different
race races race different races
damn just in the middle of it is just
like just like a it's just the Olympics
it's just black white which is the best
your race pick your race pick your race
race Wars yeah
do a little Iron Man machine yeah yeah
uh Ryan we do the jokes
God willing I finished the race I gotta
figure out if I'm gonna get the tattoo
like right after
any ideas on where I should get it so is
the thing you just get a tattoo no the m
the m dot like the logo oh oh the MDOT
dude you know what I think you should do
third eye
dot m in between your eyes Okay anywhere
else margin oh oh shave a patch in the
back of your head and have them do
anything grow their hair back over oh
yeah okay you're be kind of cool
behind your globe
wouldn't I yeah wouldn't that just hurt
like hell I got big big lobes what did
Tom say about chicks earlobes yeah yeah
it's like like Barnacle meat
you got thick earlobes
I know but don't talk about yeah nema's
gonna get pissed at us yeah Nema got mad
I texted our group Furious some pretty
funny comments last week
really don't waste this this dude I saw
that one too don't waste 10 minutes so
we won't waste a second Nema was mad
well because Nema doesn't follow
instructions so
didn't you didn't you insert my audio
recording of saying skip to this
timestamp he texts us he's like you guys
said succession and I'm freaking out
because uh like I haven't watched I'm on
episode three and
freaking out and then he like multiple
texts and then he's like hey uh I don't
know where to go and I'm like dude it
should help tell you where to skip to
he's like I fast forwarded 10 minutes
and you're still talking about it I'm
I'm not listening to this episode
anymore
he's like I'll just tune into the next
one it's probably on his phone in his
Tesla while it's automatically driving
yeah he's like oh I'm freaking out
of the first season yeah yeah
it's gonna be crazy when you find out
that
it's not got that out
do you remember those classic videos of
people driving by the people waiting in
line to see Harry Potter yeah yeah
screaming Snape kills Dumbledore they're
like
yeah
and they're like waiting in line like
dressed up to see the movie
and there are people like drive by with
a megaphone Snape kills Dumbledore Snape
kills Dumbledore no the the best one
dude was uh you remember Leroy Jenkins
yeah yeah
there was a video yeah yeah there's a
there's a meme version of that where
like started and then it hard Cuts you
know what I'm talking about yeah and
it's just that Windows Movie Maker edit
and it's just all the spoilers of Harry
Potter like on turbo like like if you
even accidentally watched three seconds
it just [__] up like five books dude
did you see the thing about
um
[Laughter]
I've been watching uh
I finished beef
don't talk about what you've been
watching dude oh yes don't waste a
minute talking about what you've been we
both like watching shows that doesn't
matter me on my fridge yeah
me my Apple watch me and my home theater
and it's we've talked about shows
Forever on this show don't waste a
[__] minute so whoever left that
comment if you're gonna talk about beef
I'm leaving
because you haven't seen it I've seen
two
episodes yeah I mean it was just [__]
crazy Danny dies
[Laughter]
crazy ass scene when Stephen Yoon Falls
die on that mountain
now those things don't actually run over
by a car they don't happen yeah they
don't happen
or do they the last episode was weird as
[__] though
which one was it nah never mind we can't
talk about it God damn it don't talk
about talk about other things
else is there in life dude um I lost all
my money this weekend I did stand up
what else do you want to know yeah no
I'm kidding there's nothing more in life
other than gambling and watching TV
shows yeah dude
yeah that's it now
yeah
we're 50. we're out for 15 we're out of
time we're 50 years old dude it's
gambling in TV the mind has an
incredible appetite for losing money
yeah it's crazy how a human brain can
just be okay like
you know oh yeah
do you know the craziest [__] last time
me and Stephen went to Vegas there was
this lady playing two cows machines
I'm down five
really just smashing too we're like get
the [__] get out of here
G.I Joe PSA what the [__] get the [__]
out of here
no I think the solution is add one more
thing three yeah like she's playing
bongos
that actually would be funny to just
occupy a whole people do that whole
cabinet and they're just walking up and
down like can I get it sit down and
they're like no no you're gonna
interrupt the flow this is mine yeah
dude
Goa if you're if you're gonna go man
I think you gotta Get Saucy then you
gotta do a high roller slot oh yeah ten
dollar spin yeah I would do that
actually I would do it I would put in
100 bucks and just lose it all just to
say that I did it
10 spins okay 100 bucks 10 spins well of
course I would hope that I would hit
some sort of win I think you go a
thousand to see if you can get like
three or four hundred and then you're
done uh yeah yeah okay yeah that's the
Dana White strategy yeah well The Dana
White strategy is uh
yeah I don't pay my Fighters anything
and I take what I would have given them
and I put it all on black
howlerhead.com I put it on double zero
very rarely hits has never hit for me
personally the odds of this thing
hitting are it's like one in a million
but it doesn't [__] matter because
it's not money that I give a [__] about
and it's money that my Fighters would
have never made yeah
it's not technically mine it's theirs
but I have it
foreign